Las urnas han hablado.
Y dejan un mapa político tremendamente complicado.
Lo único que parece claro es que, frente
a todos los pronósticos, Alberto Núñez
Feijóo no será presidente, al menos por
ahora.
Pedro Sánchez, una vez más, se ha salido
con la suya.
Ha conseguido lo que hace apenas unas pocas
semanas parecía imposible.
Haya o no repetición de elecciones ahora
es el gran favorito para mantener la presidencia
del gobierno en España.
Pero…
¿Qué explica este repentino cambio?
¿Es que acaso la derecha no logró movilizar
a sus bases?
¿En qué consistió y dónde ha fallado la
estrategia del candidato del Partido Popular?
¿Qué puede suponer todo esto para el país?
Arranquemos.
El Partido Popular ha sido la fuerza más
votada.
Pero no, España por ahora no tendrá un nuevo
presidente.
A estas horas es prácticamente imposible
que Alberto Núñez Feijóo pueda desalojar
a Sánchez.
Con algo más de 11.125.000 votos y 169 escaños,
la suma de PP y VOX se quedó muy cerca de
la mayoría absoluta.
Muy cerca, pero lo suficientemente lejos de
poder formar gobierno.
El PSOE del Pedro Sánchez logró contra todo
pronóstico subir casi 1 millón de votos,
lo que le permitió al bloque de izquierdas
aguantar el envite.
Chapó por Sánchez, ha logrado lo que parecía
imposible.
Y digo contra todo pronóstico porque esta
ha sido una de las legislaturas más difíciles,
controvertidas y polémicas de la historia
democrática de España.
Ahora con estos resultados se abren dos grandes
alternativas: que Sánchez logre el respaldo
de Bildu, PNV, Esquerra y BNG junto a la abstención
de Junts.
La otra y, quizás, la más probable, es que
España vuelva a votar dentro de unos meses.
Unas elecciones dónde la narrativa habría
cambiado por completo y dónde Sánchez sería
probablemente el gran favorito.
Si me preguntáis por mi opinión personal,
y evidentemente no es más que eso, una opinión
personal - nadie tiene una bola de cristal
- os diría que nos guste más o nos guste
menos, en estos momentos, con los resultados
que tenemos, Sánchez será presidente otra
legislatura.
España se aleja así de la enorme corriente
de cambio político en toda Europa.
Porque, hoy, exceptuando a España, solo 5
de los 26 gobiernos restantes de la Unión
Europea se inclinan a la izquierda
Ahora bien, ¿Qué demonios ha ocurrido?
¿Por qué los pronósticos parecen haber
fallado tanto?
¿Por qué la derecha o el centro-derecha
tenía unas expectativas tan altas?
Pues en cierto modo ya os lo hemos contado
aquí en VisualPolitik.
Sánchez partía de una posición muy comprometida.
Y no lo digo solo por el resultado adverso
en las pasadas autonómicas y municipales,
sino esencialmente por los escándalos, las
controversias y las pifias políticas que
ha protagonizado.
La lista es larga…
Muy larga.
Tan solo durante el último año y medio podemos
contar las siguientes “hazañas”:
Pedro le “entregó” el Sahara a Marruecos
sin dar ninguna explicación, sin contar con
los partidos de la oposición, sin garantías
para los saharauis y sin recibir nada a cambio;
Además, puso en un brete la relación económica
con Argelia y perdió uno de los grandes elementos
de presión de Madrid a Rabat.
Y no, el control de la inmigración ilegal
no justifica este cambio, porque no garantiza
que Marruecos mañana diga donde dije, digo,
digo Diego.
Pero esto es solo el comienzo:
También, le ha echado mucha cara y ha intentado
sacar tajada de la guerra de Ucrania, pese
a que España es uno de los países que menos
ayuda le ha dado a este país;
Ha impulsado cambios improvisados en el código
penal contrarios a su programa de campaña
y basados en una turbia negociación política.
Al mejor estilo de una partida de póker.
Llevó a cabo indultos que había prometido
no otorgar.
Ha establecido un temerario impuesto contra
las grandes fortunas, un impuesto al patrimonio
que prácticamente todos los países de Europa
han desechado por sus calamitosas consecuencias;
Ha sacado adelante un cambio en el modelo
de trabajadores autónomos que va a ocasionar
mucho dolor durante los próximos años;
Ha enmarañado la reforma del sistema de pensiones
hasta anunciar una supuesta hucha mientras
el sistema tiene un boquete enorme.
Sacó adelante una ley, la ley del solo Sí
es Sí, que luego tuvo que ser reformada,
pero que por el camino supuso beneficios penitenciarios
para más de 1.100 abusadores sexuales.
Incluso, para colmo llegó a provocar una
enorme crisis institucional atacando y deslegitimado
al Tribunal Constitucional, en el cual, por
cierto, terminó metiendo a personas tan independientes
como un antiguo ministro de su propio gobierno.
Y, queridos, amigos, amigas, seguro que nos
dejamos un montón de cosas en el tintero.
Y eso que hablamos tan solo del último año
y medio.
¡De locos!
Si miramos más atrás, la lista sería interminable.
A ver, por supuesto, también ha tenido logros,
pero lo cierto es que Sánchez ha ido de escándalo
en escándalo.
Y pese a todo ha resistido.
Pero es que eso ni siquiera es todo.
Tras unos años políticos, agotadores, donde
ha ocurrido prácticamente de todo, lo cierto
es que las cosas tampoco han ido para tirar
cohetes.
(En esta última legislatura, España ha sido
uno de los países con peor desempeño económico
de toda la Unión Europea.
Por mucho que se empeñe Sánchez, esto es
algo incontestable.
Entre el último trimestre del 2019 y el primer
trimestre del 2023 el PIB de España apenas
creció un 0,1%.
De hecho, de todos los 46 países de la OCDE
España se sitúa en el puesto 44 si hablamos
de la recuperación económica post-COVID.)
44 de 46.
Y eso a pesar de que Sánchez ha gastado a
manos llenas.
(Si en 2019 el gasto público fue del 42,3%
del PIB, en 2022 - ya pasada la pandemia - fue
del 47,8%.
Ha sido una de las mayores expansiones de
gasto público de todos los países desarrollados.
En Euros contantes y sonantes estamos hablando
de un incremento del gasto de más de 100
mil millones de euros cada año.)
Lo que explica, entre otras cosas, las subidas
de impuestos y también que la deuda pública
se haya incrementado en más de 350 mil millones
de euros.
Es decir, una economía dopada que pese a
ello ni mucho menos ha brillado.
Y para, colmo, la inflación y la subida de
tipos, dos cuestiones que no tienen que ver
estrictamente con España, pero que, lógicamente,
han hecho mucho daño en el bolsillo de muchas
familias.
Y pese a todo, Sánchez ha resistido.
[Hay que reconocerlo: estamos ante todo depredador
político.]
Ahora bien, ¿Qué explica exactamente el
resultado?
¿Es que acaso la derecha ha pinchado?
¿Ha pinchado Feijóo como apuntan algunos?
Pues lo cierto es que no.
Pero para analizarlo lo primero que tenemos
que tener en cuenta su estrategia política.
Y es que, veréis, desde los años 90 España
ha tenido esencialmente dos grandes formaciones
políticas: el Partido Socialista Obrero Español,
en la izquierda moderada, y el Partido Popular,
en la derecha moderada.
Sin embargo, en el año 2008, el entonces
Partido Popular de Mariano Rajoy comenzó
un giro estratégico: comenzó a intentar
transitar hacia el centro.
Un cambio de posicionamiento que tras el paréntesis
de Pablo Casado ahora ha querido consolidar
Alberto Núñez Feijóo.
N1(9 de diciembre de 2022.
El PP apuesta por persistir en la moderación
y el centro para ganar a Sánchez.
Cope)
Esto es algo que, por ejemplo, se refleja
perfectamente en esta lona electoral que el
propio Partido Popular colocó en Madrid durante
esta pasada campaña:
En ella podéis ver los colores de las diferentes
formaciones que hay en España.
El objetivo de este mensaje es bastante claro:
El Partido Popular se presenta ya no como
un partido esencialmente de derechas, sino
fundamentalmente como un partido de centro,
lo que podríamos denominar como un partido
de aglomeración capaz de recoger muchos votos
de los electores más moderados y menos ideologizados.
Por ejemplo, los votos perdidos por Ciudadanos.
Y a ver, podréis tener mejor o peor opinión
de esta formación política…
Pero si tomamos su discurso, su programa y
sus acciones de gobierno, el Partido Popular
es hoy esencialmente un partido socialdemócrata
de centro.
Vale, lo sé, muchos no estaréis de acuerdo
y seguro que muchos estaréis diciendo…
Pero, Enrique…
¿Qué barbaridad estás diciendo?
Pues parad un momento y pensadlo bien:
El Partido Popular de hoy no es un partido
particularmente conservador: apoya los derechos
LGTBI, la legislación de género, su líder
no es partidario de restringir el aborto,
no es contrario ni tiene recelos hacía la
inmigración y es un partido tremendamente
europeísta.
Lo que diga Bruselas va a misa.
Por otra parte, tampoco es un partido particularmente
capitalista o liberal.
Defiende la economía de mercado, sí, pero
una economía de mercado social:
Es partidario de aliviar algo los impuestos,
pero no mucho, siempre manteniéndolos en
la escala alta a nivel internacional.
No es partidario de recortar el gasto público
ni tampoco de limitar el campo de actuación
del Estado.
Está a favor de la redistribución de la
riqueza, de los impuestos progresivos, de
la lucha contra el cambio climático y durante
esta campaña su líder ha dicho que no liberalizará
el mercado laboral y que apuesta por garantizar
por ley la revalorización de las pensiones
conforme al IPC.
Nos podrá gustar más o menos, pero en la
esfera internacional…
Es difícil, muy, pero que muy difícil, ver
al actual Partido Popular como un partido
de derechas.
N2 (El PP pide el voto para Feijoo a los socialsistas
desencantados.
La Voz de Galicia)
C1 ("Consultaré a Felipe González de forma
intensa si soy presidente del Gobierno [...] No
oculto que tengo una relación que se puede
considerar de amistad con [los líderes socialistas]
Fernández Vara, con García-Page, con Lambán,
con Barbón o con el ya expresidente de Canarias.
Alberto Núñez Feijóo en declaraciones al
diario El Confidencial)
Todo esto es algo que también podemos ver
perfectamente en los barones regionales de
esta misma formación.
N3 (28 de junio 2023: Andalucía contará
con su primera estrategia de igualdad de trato
hacia el colectivo LGTBI.
Juanma Moreno defiende combatir la violencia
machista y el cambio climático.
El Español)
Incluso, me vais a matar, pero pensad en la
propia Isabel Díaz Ayuso…
Supuestamente, un verso suelto, la parte más
a la derecha del PP.
Pues bien, más allá de sus declaraciones,
¿cuáles son sus medidas políticas más
conocidas?
Pues medidas como estas…
N4 (28 de marzo de 2023: Ayuso lanza un plan
para triplicar las viviendas públicas a precios
asequibles y acelerar los nuevos desarrollos.
20 Minutos)
N5 (El abono transporte será gratuito para
los mayores de 65 años en Madrid.
Expansión)
Y por supuesto, y sobre todo tenemos, claro
está, a Alberto Núñez Feijóo.
El líder del Partido Popular ha dirigido
durante 13 años el gobierno de Galicia…
Y la verdad, no podemos decir que haya sido
ni particularmente conservador ni liberal.
Por ejemplo, bajo su presidencia, Galicia
fue la primera comunidad autónoma en aprobar
una ley contra la discriminación sexual,
al tiempo que se convirtió en una de las
más voraces fiscalmente.
El Índice Autonómico de Competitividad fiscal
posiciona Galicia en la parte baja de la tabla,
en la posición número 12.
No son cosas que asociaríamos a un perfil
prototípico de la derecha.
Que luego en campaña se dice de todo, pero
lo cierto es que Feijóo siempre tuvo la fama
de ser muy progre.
Pues bien, esta evolución hacia el centro
es lo que el conocido consultor político
y ex-jefe de gabinete del propio Pedro Sánchez,
Iván Redondo, ha definido como el intento
de regresar a 1977.
(De esta forma, el Partido Popular intentaría
ocupar el espectro político que en su día
ocupó la UCD de Adolfo Suárez.
Una especie de partido de aglomeración.
A su izquierda tendría al PSOE y a la derecha
sustituyendo a la antigua Alianza Popular
- que era el propio Partido Popular antes
de cambiar de nombre - a Vox.)
La pregunta es, ¿ha funcionado esta estrategia?
Hoy muchos están diciendo que Feijóo ha
fracasado porque no ha logrado movilizar.
La pregunta es, ¿es esto así?
Pues no del todo.
Me explico, aunque pueda sorprenderte este
23 de julio, la estrategia de Feijóo de situarse
más en el centro y dejar a Vox la derecha
funcionó.
Este bloque logró más de 11.125.000 votos,
lo que supone todo un récord.
El centro-derecha movilizó más que nunca
y prácticamente está cerca de su techo si
es que no lo ha tocado ya.
En España el voto de la derecha tiende a
ser más fiel, pero la izquierda tiene más
potencial de voto.
Pues bien, en estas elecciones no es que la
descafeinada campaña de Feijóo o sus choques
con Vox hayan desmovilizado a la derecha.
Para nada.
Incluso en una comunidad como Madrid, estos
dos partidos tuvieron casi 100 mil votos más
que en las pasadas autonómicas.
La estrategia de aglomeración de Feijóo
sirvió para optimizar el voto del centro-derecha,
el problema es que no le permitió llegar
al centro-izquierda ni tampoco desmovilizar
a sus votantes.
Todo lo contrario, este 23 de julio la izquierda
logró una enorme movilización.
El mensaje del miedo ante la llegada de Vox
defendido por Sánchez y el rechazo de muchos
españoles a esta formación política fue
más que suficiente para movilizar a más
de 12 millones de votantes.
Este es el motivo por que el Feijóo no es
presidente.
Quizás el mayor error de todo es haber presentado
una campaña descafeinada.
Feijóo se ha dedicado a esquivar el mayor
número de temas posibles, tener un perfil
bajo y presentarse únicamente como alternativa
al “sanchismo”.
(VIDEO SANCHISMO)
¿El problema?
El problema es que la campaña vacía del
PP ha hecho que Vox al final haya sido un
tema absolutamente principal y determinante.
No ha habido nada más.
Y al final mensajes como “que te vote Txapote”
han conseguido exactamente lo contrario a
su objetivo.
Ustedes con esto del sanchismo que dicen PP
y VOX y que al final lo que demuestran es
que PP y VOX son lo mismo han llegado ustedes
hasta incluso a verter esta maldad del “que
te vote Txapote”, “Que te vote Txapote”
señor Feijoo
Eso es algo que el Partido Socialista y también
Sumar han sabido explotar a las mil maravillas.
Y es algo que ahora tanto en el PP como en
Vox tendrán que reflexionar de cara a un
posible adelanto electoral.
Unos para diseñar una campaña más constructiva
y otros para ser menos radicales.
Ahora bien, no solo el PP ha hecho una campaña
vacía…
Lo que nos lleva directamente a la segunda
parte de este vídeo.
Atentos.
T1 (LAS GRANDES AUSENCIAS)
Me vais a llamar iluso, pero se supone que
las campañas políticas son el mejor escenario
para hacer una radiografía y plasmar una
narrativa del país que persigue cada partido
político.
Esta campaña, por ejemplo, podría haber
sido una de las mejores: problemas y retos
los hay para dar y tomar.
Sin embargo, este no ha sido el caso.
Sí, hemos visto a un Pedro Sánchez ir a
platos y a medios que no visitaba desde hace
años; hemos visto a un Feijóo sacar sobresaliente
en escapismo, básicamente se ha dedicado
a esquivar todas la balas y no decir nada.
E, incluso, hemos visto planchar a una vicepresidenta
del gobierno y vídeos como este:
No es una broma.
Esta ha sido una campaña que ha tenido dos
lemas o conceptos políticos estrella…
Por decirlo de alguna forma.
Qué te vote Txapote….
Y Perro Sánchez en lugar de Pedro Sánchez.
Y la verdad, poco más.
Y eso que España, queridos amigos, es el
país con más desempleo de la OCDE y el país
con más desempleo juvenil de toda Europa.
Hablamos de un país que ha pasado de suponer
el 1,87% del PIB mundial en el año 2005 al
entorno del 1,30% en la actualidad.
Pues bien, nada de esto ha tenido mucho protagonismo
en campaña.
De hecho, podemos poner sobre la mesa, 3 grandes
temas que han pasado completamente desapercibidos
y que, sin embargo, marcarán la agenda política
de los próximos años.
Primero, el tema estrella: el envejecimiento
demográfico y las pensiones.
Ningún candidato ha planteado ninguna reforma
más allá de seguir revalorizándolas…
Pese a que las matemáticas aquí son bastante
claras…
No se puede.
O mejor dicho, hoy no conviene y mañana no
se podrá.
(Si para finales de los años 90, las personas
con 65 o más años suponían el 13% de toda
la población, hoy son ya casi el 20% y en
2050, 1 de cada 3 españoles estará en esta
franja de edad.
Esto explica por qué en 2023 el sistema de
pensiones tiene un boquete presupuestario
real de más de 40.000 millones de euros.
Mientras que el gasto en pensiones se situará
en unos 190 mil millones, la recaudación
por cotizaciones sociales será de poco más
de 150 mil.
Y lo peor está por llegar.)
Pero…
¿Qué más da?
En campaña, básicamente todo se ha limitado
a decir que hay que seguir subiendo las pensiones.
(Por supuesto, tampoco se ha hablado de incentivar
el ahorro privado ni de planes para reciclar
a los trabajadores o para extender la vida
laboral más allá de los 67 años.
Por ejemplo, mientras que en Nueva Zelanda
el 20% de la población mayor de 65 años
trabaja, en España este porcentaje es de
solo el 5%.)
Segundo, tampoco se ha dicho prácticamente
nada sobre Impuestos, productividad o competitividad.
Sí, lo sé, Feijóo ha prometido una ligerísima
rebaja del IRPF y en la izquierda han estado
hablando de los ricos…
Pero de cambios, cambios de verdad, nada de
nada.
Y eso si hablamos de impuestos, lo de la productividad
y la competitividad, eso no se contempla ni
como temas suplentes.
Por ejemplo, en el conocido Índice de Competitividad
que elabora la escuela de negocios suiza IMD,
España se ha dejado en su última edición
11 puestos respecto a 2018.
Y en lo que respecta a productividad…
Bueno, digamos que desde los años 80, la
productividad en España se ha reducido estrepitosamente.
Esto quiere decir que con el mismo número
de trabajadores y máquinas, ahora somos incapaces
de producir más de lo que producíamos hace
40 años.
Pues prácticamente ni una palabra.
En tercer lugar, podríamos mencionar otro
gran desaparecido: la educación.
Las últimas evaluaciones muestran que España
sigue cayendo en los rankings internacionales.
Lo que explica que veamos noticias como esta:
N6 (16 de mayo de 2023: Los alumnos de 10
años de España van en lectura casi un curso
escolar por detrás de los de Inglaterra.
El Mundo)
N7 (3 de octubre de 2022: La OCDE advierte
de que el 28% de los jóvenes españoles no
tiene terminado el Bachillerato ni la FP,
el porcentaje más alto de la UE.
El Mundo.)
Y no solo eso.
España también es uno de los países con
más jóvenes que ni estudian ni trabajan.
Ni más ni menos que 1 de cada 5.
Muy por encima de la media europea y de la
OCDE.
(Y eso por no hablar de la universidad, donde
menos del 40% de los estudiantes terminan
sus estudios en tiempo.
Y luego está el problema de la formación.
El problema de la calidad y del tipo de formación.
Por ejemplo, el porcentaje de estudiantes
que optan por carreras de ciencias, ingeniería,
tecnología o matemáticas es muy bajo…
Pese a que hay una enorme escasez de profesionales
en esos sectores.)
Por supuesto, todo esto son cosas que afectan
a los niveles de productividad que veíamos
antes.
Y no, no se trata de un problema de presupuesto
ni de medios.
Por ejemplo, el gasto por estudiante teniendo
en cuenta la diferencia de precios de Estonia
es más bajo que el de España, y, aun así,
tiene el mejor sistema educativo de toda Europa.
Tampoco es un problema de profesores:
En España hay 10,8 millones de estudiantes
y casi 1 millón de profesores.
En los centros públicos hablamos de 10,4
estudiantes por profesor.
Una cifra bastante razonable.
Es sobre todo un problema de modelo y de enfoque.
Y de eso en la campaña prácticamente nada
de nada.
Os hemos hablado de todos estos problemas
largo y tendido en nuestro canal hermano VisualEconomik.
Os dejo algunos enlaces en la descripción.
Pero ya lo veis, son temas que no han aparecido
en la campaña.
Una campaña donde todo ha sido escoger entre
acabar con el sanchismo y frenar a Vox.
Y si la derecha ha movilizado a los suyos,
la izquierda también lo ha hecho.
¿Resultado?
Feijóo no será presidente.
La pregunta es, ¿Qué pensáis qué ocurrirá
ahora?
¿Qué os parece el nuevo escenario político
de España?
Amigos, dejadnos vuestras impresiones en los
comentarios y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
dale a like y suscribete VisualPolitik si
es que aún no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.